as many of you might be familiar with
the Europe 2020 conference now requires
authors to include a section in their
submissions discussing the broader
impact of their work including possible
societal consequences both positive and
negative that was announced in the
getting started with nerves 2020
announcement on medium by the conference
organizers shortly after that in an
email to Venture Beat Michael Lippmann
the communications chair of NURBS 2020
told VentureBeat that these statements
will be published with each paper
however they'll appear only in the
camera-ready versions of the papers so
they do not compromise the double-blind
nature of the reviewing process but then
goes on to say reviewers and area chairs
assessment will be done on the basis of
technical contributions only however if
a paper is flat for potential ethical
concerns then the paper will be sent to
another set of reviewers with expertise
in ethics and machine learning the final
acceptance of these papers is contingent
on the positive assessment by these
second set of reviewers as well so this
seems a bit odd for one the broader
impact statement is only published after
the double-blind reviewing process is
over but the papers will be assessed
based on their ethical and societal
impact
so maybe the assessment will have
nothing to do with this statement let's
dive in a bit deeper in the NURBS 2020
FAQ do I have to complete the broader
impact section the answer is yes please
include the section but they say however
if your work is very theoretical or is
general enough that there is no
particular application for seen then you
are free to write a broader impact
discussion is not applicable so until
now I genuinely feel that the conference
organizers view this as some sort of
experiment and it is reasonable if it
doesn't apply to you which is probably
the case for most people then
you can simply write this does not apply
to our research can my submission be
rejected solely on the basis of the
broader impact section
answer no reviewers will be asked to
rate a submission based on the
evaluation criteria not your broader
impact section they will also be asked
to check whether the broader impact
section is adequately addressed so
reviewers will be able to check the
broader impact section which isn't there
or is it there during the double-blind
reviewing process but they only have to
say whether it's adequately addressed
and they will not be able to reject a
paper on that basis again they repeat
the authors can simply state this work
does not present any foreseeable
societal consequences if the authors
feel that this is the case if this is
not the case the conference asks of the
authors to discuss along the lines of
positive potential impacts and negative
potential impacts of these submission so
far so good let's actually look at these
evaluation criteria that they asked
reviewers to grade the paper by which as
they say has nothing to do with the
broader impact section papers that
violate the style have already been
published or have fatal flaws may be
rejected on that basis other submissions
will be judged on the basis of their
technical quality novelty put potential
impact and clarity but one could still
think that the potential impact here is
a potential technical impact has nothing
to do with this broader impact section
that has nothing to do with you being
accepted or rejected they go on to say
submissions will also be considered on
ethical grounds regardless of scientific
quality or contribution and they say a
subpoena submission may be rejected for
ethical considerations now again one
could say that they don't look at your
broader impact statement if they feel
that there's an ethical violation they
reject it but before we've already heard
if the reviewers feel that there is an
ethical consideration that may include
the broader impact section they can flag
the paper and that will go to set second
reviewers and these reviewers can
actually reject your paper so it seems
like there is a bit of a mixed message
here the entire question sort of hinges
on who makes the decision and based on
what and one of the questions is what
kind of decisions do the reviewers make
so where else better to go than the
reviewer guidelines question 11 - the
reviewers half the authors adequately
address the broader impact of their work
including potential negative ethical and
societal implications of their work
indicate whether you believe the broader
impact section was adequate so it feels
like that the reviewers are simply to
evaluate whether this has done with
enough work and not necessarily whether
they agree with the broader impact
section or not the question here is if
the reviewers think that this has not
been done with enough adequacy but don't
necessarily see an ethical problem or
actually do can it be rejected on the
basis that it has not been done
adequately the entire writing here seems
like it should but then also it seems
like the reviewers assessment should
have nothing to do with the broader
impact section question 12 of the
reviewer guidelines says does the
submission raise potential ethical
concerns note that this is a different
question from question 11 where you're
simply asked to judge adequacy the
reviewer guidelines say note that your
rating should be independent of this if
the AC also shares this concern
dedicated reviewers with expertise at
the intersection of ethics and machine
learning will further review the
submission and your duty is to flag the
papers this now seems that reviewers are
to consider the adequacy of the
statement but not its content and
forward its content to another section
which contradicts that the reviewers
don't see the statement or that the
statement can't influence the review and
it also contradicts the statement that
your paper
cannot be rejected based on the broader
impact section namely if the second set
of reviewers read your broader impact
section find it doesn't address their
concerns they can in fact reject your
paper based on that I guess someone
arguing against that would say that
these people could also reject it just
because they think it's ethically
problematic but if a paper has a broader
impact section I think they are going to
look at that with some sort of an open
mind and at least be influenced by that
in a note for submitting authors the
conference organizers again released a
statement saying that the broader impact
statement should include a statement
about the foreseeable positive impact as
well as potential risks associated
mitigations of the proposed research
authors can also declare that a broader
impact statement is not applicable to
their work if they believe this to be
the case and they again repeat reviewers
will also confirm whether the broader
impact statement is inadequate but this
assessment will not affect the overall
rating howevers reviewer have the option
to flag a paper for ethical concerns
which may relate to the content of the
broader impact section the paper will be
sent for additional review to a pool of
emergency reviewers with expertise in
machine learning and ethics who will
provide an assessment solely on the
basis of ethical considerations we
expect very few of any papers to need
such further assessment so the official
communication makes it divided between
on one hand adequacy and on the other
hand real ethical concerns and their
message is basically reviewers will
judge the adequacy flag the ethical
concerns and then special reviewers will
be able to reject based on ethical
concerns
now what's not really clear is the
messaging that reviewers should not base
their judgment on the broader impact
section but then where does this
adequacy rating go into the process of
rejecting or accepting a paper and with
them saying there will only be a few
they expect only a few it seems like
it's sort of an experiment that they
do this year oh hey new ribs organizer
well hello so you've decided to make
everyone include a broader impact
statement but the broader impact
statement will only be visible after the
reviewing process correct but the
reviewers should check its adequacy
during the review process yes while they
can't see it correct but it should in no
way influence their judgement and who
can't be rejected because of that that
is correct but if it is found to be
inadequate or problematic it is sent to
a second set of reviewers which on the
basis of the paper and the broader
impact statement will decide if the
paper is of ethical concern yes and if
the paper is of the North achill concern
and the broader impact statement doesn't
convince these special reviewers
otherwise they will be able to reject
that paper that is indeed correct so how
are you saying that the broader impact
statement has no influence on your score
and you can't be rejected because of it
well as we said no one's able to see it
until the paper is released obviously
let's talk about these special reviewers
and for that we broadly have to talk
about incentives now just imagine for a
second that this expectation comes to
fruit that no paper is actually flagged
and for any paper that is flagged to
this committee we'll come back with a
clear no this is not really an ethical
concern or a reason to discard this
paper as a scientific contribution one
might almost think that then this
program will be abolished in the next
year because it's useless so the more
problems the special reviewers find the
more justified their position is I
wonder where that leads I guess we are
very dependent on pretty much every
single person in these special reviewers
being some sort of super honest person
that has no incentives and also no
strong opinions on these things and and
generally has gone into this ml ethics
just out of interest and not to actually
make an impact I'm sure that will work
out just fine now the official nurbs
website actually links to a blog post of
brent hague suggestions for
Europe's 2020 broader impact statements
so we can reasonably assume that this is
at least in agreement with the
organizers of the conference brachear
says understanding the societal impacts
of your work is going to be hard it is
going to take lots of effort to Ragnar X
broader impact statements tons of work
has already been done for you
check out the literature from
communities that have studied societal
impacts of AI for a long while
even better bring a social scientist on
to your research team remember though
they don't work for free hire them into
your company give them sub-awards
recruit them as PhD students through
interdisciplinary programs so are you
saying the more problems these people
find the more of them will get hired and
again look at these statements in
general it seems to really be about how
much work are you able to put into this
so here is your average PhD student now
they pretty much already have threw out
their papers by themselves or in very
very small teams because they need first
authorship and they have to do all their
experiments and they don't have enough
resources and now they're also asked to
spend considerable amount of time not
only writing this very hard statement
but also reading up on all the
literature that there is to read up on
or alternatively if you don't want to do
that well just hire someone of course
because budgets and salaries and
universities and for PhD student is
notoriously loose we can just hire
someone that does that I don't really
think it's possible for single PhD
students or research labs at
universities to just hire someone or put
someone full-time on this additional
required work that is put onto them I
wonder who will be actually able to put
additional people on this such that they
surely end up with beautiful well
research broader impact statements to
justify even the most ethically
concerning research I'm wondering it
just can't some the tip of my tongue but
hours gonna have to leave that for
another time for people who do more
theoretical work it is going to be more
difficult wait a minute I thought the
official communication was you're very
free to leave the way if you don't think
this applies to you but here is
basically saying it's going to be more
work for you find something that is both
rigorous and practical for your research
and the argument is to get funding for
any theoretical work someone had to make
an argument about positive societal
impacts at some point not true some
universities simply get money and
academic freedom if that argument is
possible it is probably also possible to
make a rigorous statement about some
negative societal impacts you might be
tempted to write boilerplate low
information statements don't do this it
will undermine the rigor in the rest of
your paper the public will roll its eyes
and reviewers may and often should call
you out now wait a minute I thought the
reviewers are only supposed to judge the
adequacy and absolutely have no
influence on their judgement of the
paper but the underpinning of this text
here is basically that if you as a
reviewer field that this hasn't been
done adequately you sort of should let
this swap over into your assessment of
the rigor and adequacy of the technical
contributions in the paper because
they're kind of the same right and they
also say that this might spark a
conversation is specifically the author
response period will be a decent
opportunity to have a bit of a dialogue
between author and reviewer on the
impact statement
so this basically means that I as a
reviewer now have to write in my review
something about the broader impact
statement and not only judge its
adequacy in a special field for it and
then the author is forced to spend a
bunch of their very very very valuable
of the response on every bottling the
reviewers assessment of their broader
impact statement our proposals view is
that it's not your job as a reviewer to
judge submissions
for their impacts rather you should
evaluate the rigor with which they just
close their impacts so again it's about
putting work into it if you go to the
full proposal behind this blog post
you'll find the following snippets so
there is a list of expected outcomes of
introducing such mandatory broader
impact statements now have a look at
this expected outcomes we expect that
action on the above recommendations will
lead to a number of desirable outcomes
and they're all positive outcomes now
haven't we been discussing for the last
minutes that it's always important to
assess the positive and the negative
outcomes of your actions and of your
releases how ironic that none of the
organizers of the conference nor any of
these people communicating were forced
to release a broader impact statement
discussing the negative consequences
that their actions would have on the
community and the greater society they
go on to give a list of examples of how
you could do such positive and negative
aspects of technology one of them is
social media and I would agree that
there are ethical considerations if you
invent social media we all know that
social media can be some sort of a
dopamine feedback loop addiction and
have negative consequences in society
that are not readily visible but it goes
on crowd work a researcher who invents a
new crowd work framework likely
motivates her work by highlighting the
problem the framework solves but they go
on to say that crowd work also has
negative externalities such as
incentivizing very low pay and the
researcher should find ways to engineer
her crowd work framework such that these
externalities are structurally mitigated
and or she might advocate for minimum
wage laws to be adapted so this
researcher working out a problem in
crowd working now has to basically solve
millennia-old
problems in structural economics that
have thousands of moving parts and no
clear consensus on how to solve but the
best example
and this is the example they actually
tell you to look at if your work is more
theoretical or you don't really think it
has an impact is the following storage
and computation recent advances in
storage systems and graphical processing
unit processing afford the easy storage
of massive amounts of data and the
real-time computation on these data
this has incentivized corporations to
collect every possible data point about
their users save this data indefinitely
and strive to monetize this data in new
ways while allowing for impressive new
capabilities this trend also presents
tremendous risks to privacy researchers
working in storage and GPU processing
should consider it these and other
foreseeable potential risks in their
papers they should also enumerate
technological and policy means by which
these risks might be mitigated eg
technologies to automate general data
protection regulation required
capabilities and improvements to GDP are
like policies that is absolutely mad so
here you are making a GPU chip more
powerful and you're asked to think ahead
about the fact that this can be used to
mine data and not only that now you're
also required to propose improvements to
GDP or like policies the GDP are only an
88 page very fine print legal document
that in addition to all the literature
about AI governance our poor PhD student
is now also required to read understand
and be able to improve how long does
this chain of causality go how do you
have to think ahead this gets ridiculous
it's 200,000 BC and no no in his cave
just invented fire well fire can be used
to cook food can be used to have less
disease can be used to settle down
expand civilization build educational
facilities build up a culture a
scientific method enable massive
progress industrialization general
improvement in
health wealth education and happiness of
society which ultimately leads to some
people building GPUs and saving your
data and analyzing all your things to
serve you ads of better titty stickers
how could no no in his cave do this to
us where is this broader impact
statement about the invention of fire
for the future data collection
algorithms on GPUs look I'm not saying
that you should not consider the down
strings effect of your inventions of
course you should but at some point it
gets ridiculous for most of the work
handed into a conference like NURBS
either the downstreams effect are so far
away that is almost impossible to
foresee or as any technology you can use
it for good and for bad and it is going
to be with the application of this
technology and not its invention where
the good and the bad come in and what
most people are going to do is simply
come up with things that mean absolutely
nothing and generally make not a lot of
difference while it gives a big
advantage to big institutions that can
spend a lot of time and effort on
crafting very rigorous adequate
statements another release called a
guide to writing the NURBS impact
statement that is not linked by nerves
but as they say was in communication
with some of the organizers of the
conference so it's reasonable to assume
they also largely agree with these
positions here says you should discuss
read and reflect time permitting impact
assessment will benefit from broad
intellectual reflection discuss
potential impacts follow public
discussion read case studies and read
the scholarly literature on tech
governance of course time permitting but
then again if it's not rigorous enough a
reviewer might be getting the idea that
the rest of your paper isn't rigorous
enough so maybe time must permit for
this one and they again say think about
impact even for theoretical work so the
official communication always says that
if you don't feel this applies to you
you're very free to write this doesn't
apply to you but the unofficial
communication says if this doesn't apply
you're doing
something wrong and by the way we
reevaluate the rest of your paper based
on the amount of work you put into that
statement ultimately these statements
are just going to boil down to you can
do good and bad things with any
technology as is visible on this example
they appear for it was a superhuman AI
for multiplayer poker they say they're
intentionally choose to broaden the
focus of their broader impact assessment
depending who can use this scientific
advance such as criminals or well
motivated citizens this technology may
be socially harmful or beneficial if
access to this capability is mostly
available to the wealthy it could
plausibly promote concentration of
wealth and further on the other side
increased skill could increase total
welfare G if that doesn't apply to every
single technology ever I don't know
again my general assessment of this is
not that it is absolutely wrong to do
this or very useless it is just shifting
the balance a bit more on to large
institutions who can actually afford to
spend a lot of time and work into
crafting beautiful statements and in
general I don't think it's that big of a
deal but I also don't think it's going
to help very much to just force everyone
to do this I guess we'll see how it
turns out in this Venture Beat article
they link someone named Joe Redman
saying I stopped doing CV research
because I saw the impact my work was
having I loved the work but the military
applications and privacy concerns
eventually became impossible to ignore
which I respect a lot but I would ask
did Joe Redmond realize this after being
forced to write a broader impact
statement or at some other point that
was my two cents if you like videos like
this and paper analysis and other things
then subscribe like wherever these
buttons are share it with your friends
and see you next time
[Music]